c'était la rentrée des classes pour les
élèves de primaire ce lundi 26 avril
rentrée sous très haute surveillance
pose l'école maternelle de trimer après
deux semaines de vacances et une semaine
de cours à la maison un retour en classe
accompagnée d'un nouveau dispositif
sanitaire but d'entrée sous haute
surveillance avec des mesures sanitaires
strictes fermé depuis le 2 avril pour
tenter de ralentir l'épidémie de
coronavirus le gouvernement a pris la
décision de maintenir la réouverture des
classes la rentrée aura donc lieu pour
tous le 26 avril
lundi prochain ce sont les collèges et
lycées qui rouleront à leur tour leurs
portes avec l'arrivée du variant indiens
et les taux de contamination toujours
élevé des parents d'élèves et
enseignants s'inquiètent d'un retour
trop précipités pour quand est ce soit
efficace il faut tout les enfants soient
testés ça ne sera pas possible donc je
ne fais pas ça très efficace
alors fallait-il ou rouvrir les écoles
allait-il envers les écoles il ya
emmanuel macron le président qui est
d'ailleurs lui-même retour de l'école ce
matin puisqu'il a fait le tour des
classes regarder beaucoup d'enfants
c'était assez dur quand même
et puis pas que des enfants d'ailleurs
c'était dur parce qu'on avait tout était
fermé
donc là tu as ce qu'on a fait on a on a
c'est vrai beaucoup il ya des règles
très dur ça va jusque début mai et après
on va progressivement rouvrir mais ce
qu'on veut faire c'est y aller tout
doucement pour éviter que ça reparte
donc normalement avec le temps qui est
plus chaud qui s'améliore
et puis avec le fait qu'on vaccine de
plus en plus de gens et le fait qu'on a
diminué le nombre le nombre de cas parce
qu'on a fait de cet effort ces dernières
semaines à partir du début du mois de
mai on devrait progressivement réussir
tu vois tout doucement revers les choses
alors regardez on peut avoir l'image un
petit peu avant regardez chez vous
regardez un petit peu avant merci merci
anne en avant avant avant qu'il n'ya pas
le garçon là bas on vais regarder
merci merci voilà je pense que ce garçon
en vert on la paie pour lui dire la
petite est au bout du rouleau da
c'est sur le gars est alors fallait-il
vraiment ouvrir les écoles déjà silva ce
que les conditions étaient réunies pour
réouvrir les écoles aujourd'hui moi je
pense que non on ne peut pas ouvrir les
écoles dans un en étant c'est pas ça
pour tout le monde on ne peut pas
empêcher les enfants de se passer le
virus les conditions ne sont pas réunies
vous vouliez pas de sérieux c'est dans
ces conditions ça dénote la poisse à
faire ou quoi
le distanciait non plus c'est pas
l'idéal parce qu'il ya des parents qui
n'ont pas d'ordinateur qui regarde sur
un ordi qui n'ont pas de connexion
internet qu'ils font ça sur un téléphone
donc les conditions ne sont pas réunies
non plus pour travailler vous étiez pour
la fermeture à l'époque bad dans les
cellules problème c'est que les
conditions ne sont pas réunies pour
qu'on ouvre correctement parce qu'
est-ce que mode au monde et il dit une
bêtise
s'il ya un enfant c'est bien un cas dans
la dans la classe le protocole sanitaire
a été adapté il a été réhaussée
maintenant on ferme les classes dès
qu'il ya un cas de détecter dans la
classe et en plus de ça il ya des tests
ont été largement mis en place les tests
salivaires par exemple y en avait trois
cent mille avant avant les vacances
là on passe à 600 milles d'accord et les
autotests ça fera plaisir à matin martin
me lâcher parce que je sais il y en aura
deux qui vont être donnés pour les
personnels
chaque semaine et un pour les lycéens à
partir du 10 mai donc on augmente on
fait un protocole sanitaire qui est plus
stricte et qui vise à être plus
efficaces et moi je comprends que ce
soit très difficile dans les écoles et
que je sais que les enseignants font un
formidable travail mais je sais aussi
que ce qui compte pour vous c'est la
réussite de vos élèves
et vous l'avez dit le distance yens
c'est pas idéal et je vais juste donner
un chiffre
depuis 12 mois depuis mars dernier sur
mars 2010 tu peux compter
il ya dix semaines d'école qui ont été
supprimés en france c'était sur le
premier confinement pour vous donner un
exemple aux états unis depuis 12 mois
rien à 48 et donc en fait quand tu es
sur les décors et puis après ils sont
donald trump est donc là il ya une
histoire de décrochage
en fait derrière c'est une mesure c'est
de la justice sociale et vous le savez
jusque là c'est parce que les quartiers
les plus désavoué
je pose la question à martin blachier et
mots de m and m's voilà voilà les
chocolats champions les chéris jusqu'à
ce qui a changé par rapport à ya trois
semaines rien du tout il ya rien pour
vous rien du tout peu la seule mesure
c'est que si jamais un enseignant est
absent parce qu'il est qu'à contacter
les élèves ne peuvent plus être répartis
dans les classes
mais ça c'est très théorique parce que
si les parents ne peuvent pas les garder
parce qu'ils n'en n'ont pas les moyens
on est quand même obligé d accueillir
dans l'école donc que fait-on des fois
on a du personnel supplémentaire par
exemple la dame qui s'occupe un peu ou
des atsem qui peuvent les prendre mais
sinon on est obligé d accueillir
on doit changer ça vous rassure pas le
fait que les tests ont déjà parlé tout à
l'heure et personne n'a reçu et 16 dans
les échos la nuit à partir de cette
semaine les rectorats - on a reçu un
message qui était le 26 et aujourd'hui
on n'a toujours pas les rings doit être
livré aujourd'hui en france et donc vous
allez recevoir dans la terreur quand
donc les tests ça va être quand la terre
et toi ça c'est 2 à partir de cette
semaine
est-ce que ça par exemple les tests
salivaires que 120 et 600000 tu es à
l'univers parce que ça me concerne on
extrait des tests dans l'eau dans le nez
pour nous en fait pour les enseignants
mais même nous on n'a pas noté style
était sale hiver ça va être pour les
enfants et pour les enseignants vous
allez avoir les autotests il en aurait
deux par semaine c'est ce qu'on nous a
dit ce qu'il fallait rouvrir les écoles
williams ou nouvelle école il fallait
même pas les fermer
il ya les l'agencé américaine et si
d'ici là qui a fait re 72 publications
sur les contaminations dans les écoles
elle est ferme
elle cite des enfants ne participe pas à
la dynamique accordé bigot % à reflets
de la dynamique épidémique général mais
c'est pas de réouvrir les écoles qui
voit relancer les hospitalisations pour
lui convient de 19 essais été fait dans
plein de pays et à chaque fois qu'ils
ont réouvert les écoles ça n'a pas
entraîné de rebond épidémique nous met
l'école n'est qu'un reflet de ce qui se
passe dans le reste de la société cast a
guère ouvrir les écoles peut-être mais
on est d'accord que les lycées et des
collèges est plus compliqué c'est un peu
différent sur les écoles c'est sûr et là
j'ai laissé ça reste moins que les
adultes
mais les vraies questions les chiffres
sont exactement les mêmes aléas en
quatre mille près bien qu'il ya trois
semaines donc il fallait soit pas fermée
mais là aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
raison objective pourrait ouvrir vous
voulez mon avis oui je pense qu'il
n'aurait jamais dû fermer je pense qu
auront compris qu'ils auraient pas dû
fermer c'est ça il fallait
ouvrir de toute façon ça a été de faire
mais c'est pas de réouvrir voilà la
réponse a pas la fermeture elle a été
fait ces trois jours et c'est sous
pression c'est vrai mode c'est vrai je
veux bien mais ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on a prouvé plusieurs fois que
les enfants pouvaient ramener le virus à
la maison abandonnée non s'est pourtant
dit on l'a entendu et non mais enfin
c'est ben vrai ça parce que c'est vrai
que ça c'est pas prouvée saclay 91 dans
la preuve de l'inversé
ce qui est prouvé c'est que dans les
écoles quand il ya eu des contributions
nichols essentiellement passée par les
professeurs et le staff de l'école et
pas les élèves mais qui a dit ça
américaine d'épisodes logique et c'est
ce qui les contraignent à la voile comme
corps qui dit qu'ils aient jamais eu
autant d'infection par des enfants de
moins de 11 ans depuis un mois on a là
on alors mais ça c'est différent ça
c'est des forces et pas parce qu'il ya
des infections dans les écoles que ça
passe par les écoles 6 et des parents
parce qu'ils sont très affectées alors
rien on a la chance d'avoir un
spécialiste eric non pour moi oui il
fallait rouvrir les écoles et un moment
donné faut vivre avec ce virus connaît
un lent n'empêche que ce soit au bout du
rouleau et parce que lui c'est le mec
voilà qui fait le plus la fête au monde
sans déconner à l'armée je le dis lui ai
donc mais un moment donné faut vivre
avec ce virus parce que là à force c'est
que c'est compliqué la danse fois je
lisais un article à ya pas mal de
d'étudiants qui se suicider tout parce
qu'ils en ont marre d'être toujours chez
eux et tout ça c'est investir maintenant
on sait que ces données et l'a donc
fallait c'est vrai on a ouvert les
écoles mais comme l'a dit marc en tête
que voilà il fallait peut-être pas les
fermer mais en fait c'est fermé comme si
c'était une période de vacances et que
maintenant il ya 18 zones de vacances
voilà bah oui ami françois hollande il a
fait tellement de zones de vacances
pensez à lui avant c'était pas si
j'allais passer cinq ans et voilà merci
on lembras doit touré chinois sans
permis ce qu'il faudrait c'est bien pour
lui je pense qu'il faut laisser les
écolos verts passent aussi un lieu de
développement intellectuel et social
pour les enfants c'est très important
mais surtout je me mets à la place de
ceux qui disent qu'il faut les fermer ça
veut dire qu'il faut laisser fermer tout
le temps j'ai un soccer a tout le temps
une bonne raison de les fermer
on va attendre qu'il y aura toujours des
on sait que tu auras des variants encore
et encore nous dire quoi les enfants
vous êtes scola déscolarisés par les
enseignants et il faut mettre des
autotests au jazeera notos année si vous
n'aimez pas votre région dans les
gouttes éparses qui prend la décision
avant ses bras ses professeurs c'est pas
qu'il ne faut jamais les ouvrir c'est
qu'il ne faut pas les ouvrir des
conditions pareilles on voit que votre
discours au fait bien quelqu'un qui
n'est pas allé dans une école depuis
longtemps en tout cas ils sont jamais
allés au temps passé en faisant évoluer
les gens maternelle n'ont pas de masque
donc comment voulez vous qu il ne se
passe pas le moindre microbes et ensuite
en élémentaire il faut voir comment ils
ont le masque ils ont tout le temps le
nez qui dépasse malgré notre vigilance
est même tout ce qui est protocole
sanitaire se laver les mains c'est très
très compliqué deleuze de l'établir
ouvrir les fenêtres tout le temps c'est
c'est un casse-tête pas possible c'est
le système d en permanence on perd des
heures à faire respecter un protocole
qui de toute façon ne marche pas alors
oui les immondes plus on ne dit pas que
c'est facile d'ouvrir les écoles et bien
sûr que les les contraintes que ça
apporte vous devez porter au quotidien
c'est extrêmement difficile mais on
croit en tout cas moi c'est ma
conviction que malgré tout on doit faire
cet effort là et que tant qu'on peut on
doit ouvrir les écoles parce que on
parle de décrochage scolaire ce
qu'effectivement l'école c'est apprendre
mais c'est pas que apprendre en fait
c'est la sociabilisation c'est ce qui
fait que vous rencontrez les élèves qui
sont bas vous le savez vous le savez
qu'ils sont différents de vous c'est
aussi une histoire de santé parce qu'un
enfant qui va à l'école c'est un enfant
qui mangent à la cantine et donc c'est
un vrai repas ce qui n'est pas le cas
partout
c'est pour ça que ce choix-là du
président de la république c'est un
choix éthique etc sachez qu'il est
président jean michel blanquer
c'est d'abord la volonté du président de
la république et puis ensuite c'est une
volonté évidemment qu'elle était portée
par jean michel blanquer
marais dépenses à cette décision
évidemment porté par le président de la
république alors on regarde et il ya de
nombreux parents qui se sont dits sont
dits soulagés regards depuis une petite
vingtaine travailler de la maison alors
on n'est pas professeur on a nos métiers
aussi à côté il faut travailler
fondamental qu'ils soient en relation
avec les autres les adultes et les
enfants et leurs familles donc il faut
qu'ils soient à l'école c'était dur à
gérer le boulot professionnels et
l'école à la maison qu'on n'a pas la
même patience que les professeurs entend
parfaitement ce que dit sylvain on n'a
pas assez protéger les enseignants on
aurait dû tous les vacciner mais
néanmoins sylvain vous savez très bien
qu'il ya des enfants quand ils sont chez
eux ils sont soumis à des violences
ils sont soumis à une inégalité de
l'apprentissage il ya des familles qui
peuvent pas même en distance yale avec
les outils assurer l'avenir de leurs
enfants intellectuelle donc c'est trop
dangereux pour les enfants moi je suis
un maniaque de la réouverture des écoles
vous attendais parce qu'isabelle où il
vote si si il y retourne à l'école de
mon fils il un télétravail depuis trois
ans
on envoie son fils et on l'envoie son
fils deux ans encore et la retraite
attention il vous regarde pour
l'embrasser dit ce que dit benjamin
marabout qu'est ce qui a changé par
rapport à il ya trois semaines avec tout
con ce qu'a rappelé macron c'est le
temps le temps joue en faveur de temps
plus on peut être tort mais quand on a
de risques
oui d'accord merci il fallait passer la
lame et tour en anglais spaling d'accord
très bien oui merci une question la
vaccination des enseignants sont nés ou
est-ce que ça avance
combien ces créneaux dédié aux
enseignants qui sont déjà ouvertes
on a découvert il ya quelques semaines
de ça qui concerne les enseignants de
plus de 55 ans bien sûr on aimerait que
tous les enseignants puissent être
vaccinés en un claquement de doigts mais
vous le savez aujourd'hui on a encore
une contrainte que celui de
l'approvisionnement des deux est donc au
fur et à mesure qu'on reçoit ses doses
on permet à de plus en plus de personnes
d'en bénéficier mais les enseignants de
plus de 55 ans font partie mais le
public priorité on leur avait promis
falzar et au final ses astra zeneca
quand même je te précise l astra zeneca
est avec son rival à jamais le contrôle
de monsieur on avait promis ouest alors
oui 48% non à 52% voyez c'est assez
partagés et ils sont plus du côté de
sylvain